Passt, dann kommen wir jetzt zu den If-Statements, ich habe sie schon kurz da gezeigt.
Und zwar ist das einfach, wenn Bedingung erfüllt ist, dann mach das.
Also wir haben hier, if die Bedingung hier, hier habe ich jetzt zum Beispiel X ist Nann,
dann print mir das.
Sonst wird es einfach übersprungen.
Und hier wichtig für euch ist, dass ihr schaunst sollst, dass ihr immer 4 Leerzeichen eingerückt seid.
Wenn ihr wischlst, du dir kurz zum Beispiel verwendet fürs Programmieren, dann könnt ihr glaube ich auch einfach Tab drücken
und dann macht er automatisch 4 Leerzeichen.
Ich sollte da auf jeden Fall schauen, dass das eben 4 sind und nicht 2 und eben auch kein Tab.
Genau, gehen wir da kurz noch weiter.
Genau, hier zum Beispiel sieht man das, hier haben wir die Bedingung, wenn die erfüllt ist, dann wird das ausgeführt.
Falls wir aber nicht diese Bedingung erfüllen, dann wird das übersprungen, weil das praktisch hier eingerückt ist in einem Block.
Und wir gehen zu der nächsten Anweisung, die praktisch hier auf derselben Block-Intentation ist, also Einrückung ist.
Genau, und dann gibt es natürlich auch, wenn dann und dann sonst, also das Elf.
Hier im diesen Fall wird das hier immer ausgeführt, aber wir können das natürlich auch anders machen.
Wir können das sagen, okay, wir wollen das nur ausführen, falls die Kondition nicht erfüllt ist.
Das heißt, wir machen, wenn die Kondition erfüllt ist, dann bringt mir das.
Falls ihr aber nicht erfüllt ist, machen wir was anderes.
Und das kann man natürlich noch erweitern und also hier nochmal kurz wiederholen.
Dann gibt es nämlich noch das Elf dazwischen und das ist praktisch dann, wenn dann, sonst wenn dann.
Und dann ganz zum Schluss sonst.
Das heißt praktisch, wir haben hier, da kann man da ja, ein Kotbeispiel hier.
Das heißt, wir haben hier, falls unsere Kondition erfüllt ist, machen wir das, falls sie nicht erfüllt ist, schauen wir die nächste Kondition an.
Okay, die ist auch nicht erfüllt, dann schauen wir die nächste Kondition an.
Okay, die scheint auch nicht zu erfüllt sein, dann bleibt nur noch das übrig, dann wird das ausgeführt.
Falls wir irgendwo dazwischen landen, falls diese Kondition erfüllt ist, dann wird das ausgeführt, das hier wird aber nicht mehr ausgeführt.
Ist das bis jetzt so verständlich oder gibt es Fragen?
Okay. Wichtig ist, so was ist nicht gleich wie das her.
Hier im diesem Fall ist es halt wirklich so, dass wir zuerst diese Kondition schauen und wenn die nicht erfüllt ist, dann gehen wir die nächste rein.
Das ist praktisch alles ein zusammenhängender Block.
Hier im diesem Fall, das sind alles getrennte Statements.
Das heißt praktisch, wenn diese Kondition erfüllt ist, dann wird das hier gemacht, dann wird aber auch gleich diese Kondition angeschaut.
Und falls die auch erfüllt ist, dann wird das ja auch ausgebrintet.
Also hier in diesem Fall ist das nicht der Fall.
Also wenn wir hier diese Kondition erreicht haben, dann wird der Rest hier nicht mehr ausgeführt, hier aber schon.